with regard to the topic of AI alignment
right because if we tell the AI maximize
the number of rat tails
then it could like bostrom's paperclip
maximizer uh
start clear-cutting forests to grow
massive factory farms of rats and you
know whatever it you can do the reducto
ad absurdum of a very powerful system
um and
so then the question is you say okay
well
do the rat tails or the GDP or whatever
it is well also factoring this other
metric okay well you can do those two
metrics and there's still something
armed what about these three the
question is is there a finite
describable set of things that is
adequate for something that can do
uh optimization that powerfully right
that is a way of thinking and so it's is
there a
finitely describable definition of good
is another way of thinking about it
right or in in terms of optimization
Theory yeah that's something I think
about the misalignment problem is that
in principle impossible to make the
explicit what's implicit when we State a
goal it carries with it manifold
unstated assumptions for instance I say
bring me coffee or bring me Uber food we
imply indirectly don't run over a
pedestrian to bring me the Uber food
don't take it from the kitchen prior to
it being packaged don't break through my
door to give it to me and we cloak all
of that and say that's just common sense
common sense is extremely difficult to
make explicit even object recognition is
extremely difficult and then as soon as
we can get a robot to do something that
is human-like then it becomes more and
more black box-like and then you have
this huge problem of interpretability of
AI so it's an extremely difficult
problem and I wonder how much of the
misalignment problem is just that is it
just the fact that we can't make
explicit what's implicit and we over
value how much the explicit matters and
implicit is far more complex I don't
know this is just something that I'm
putting out there and asking
in other words to relate this to what
you were saying is is it finite and even
if it's finite is it like a tractable
amount of finiteness that either we can
handle it or we can design an AI that we
feel like we have a handle over that can
understand it
yeah
and if you try to say okay can I
mine myself my brain for all the
implicit assumptions and put them all
I think every version of the thought
experiment you realize you can't but
even if you do
that's only the ones that are associated
with the kinds of context you've been
exposed to so far but there are a heap
of things that nobody has ever done that
maybe an AI could do
that now also have to be factored in
there that you didn't
you didn't think to say because it was
never something that happened previously
where there's evolved knowledge to say
don't do those things right
um
there's also something that
because humans all
co-evolved and have similar-ish nervous
systems and all kind of need to breathe
oxygen and want the university a world
that has similar physics and whatever
there's some stuff where the implicit
processing is kind of baked into the
evolutionary process that brought us
that is not true for a silica based
system it has totally different it is
not subject to the same physical
constraints right optimize itself in a
very different physical environment
um
and so even the thing that we would call
just kind of uh an intuitive thing is
very different for a very different type
of system
so the one
I would say when it comes to the topic
of AGI alignment
there are different positions on
alignment I would say the strongest
position
is Agi alignment is not well first we
actually have to discuss what we even
mean by alignment right because
and initially
the topic of alignment means can we
ensure that the AI is aligned with human
values and human intentions so that when
you say bring me a cup of coffee that
you're all those implicit intentions
that you have are not damaged in the
process
but if we look at the all of the animals
and factory farms in the extinct species
and the disruption to the environment
and the conflict between humans and
other humans and class subjugation and
all those things you can say human
intent is not unproblematic
and exponentiating human intent as is
is not actually an awesome solution
and so do you want it to be aligned with
human intention well it currently looks
like human intention has created a
social sphere and a technosphere that is
fundamentally misaligned with the
biosphere they depend upon and it is the
technosphere social sphere complex is
uh
kind of Auto poetically scaling
while debasing the substrate it depends
upon in other words it's on a
self-termination path
so and that represents something like
the collective intent of humans
currently in this context
so if you ensure that the AI is a is
aligned with intent in the narrow
Obvious definition that is also not a
good definition of an alignment
um so insofar as the humans are not
aligned if their intent is not aligned
with the biosphere they depend upon and
it's not aligned with the well-being of
other humans who will produce counter
responses
and most of the time isn't even aligned
with their own future good as is the
case with all addictive behavior right
sorry to interrupt I'm so sorry is this
a place where you disagree with
yadkowski or has he also expressed
points that are in alignment with your
point about alignment
I don't know if he has a there's nothing
that I know of that I disagree with I
think when he's
uh
I'm sure he's thought about this I just
haven't read that of him when he's
talking about alignment he's talking
about this more basic issue of
um as he tries to give the example if
you have a very powerful Ai and you ask
it to do something that would be very
hard for us to do but should be a
tractable task for it like replicate the
strawberry at a cellular level
that can you make an AI that could do
that that doesn't destroy the world in
the process
even that level not being clear how to
do at all is the thing he's generally
focused on I'm sure he has deeper
arguments Beyond it that if we got that
thing down what else would we have to
get
um so
uh
one could say like if we look at all of
the social media issues of the social
dilemma addressed
um where
you can say right Facebook can say we're
giving people what they want or Tick
Tock or the YouTube algorithm or
Instagram or whatever because we're not
forcing people to use it
except it's saying we're giving people
what we want in the same way that the
drug dealer who gives drugs to kids is
saying that right which is we can create
addiction we can kind of prey on the
lower angels of people's nature and if
they're individual people who don't even
know they're in such a competition and
we're talking about a major fraction of
a trillion dollar organization employing
super computers and AI in an asymmetric
Warfare against them
uh to say we are giving them what they
want while engineering what they want
that's you know it's a tricky
proposition
but we can see how the algorithm that
optimizes for in whether it's time on
site or engagement both have happened
that's a perverse
metric right because you you can get it
through driving addiction and driving
tribalism and driving fear in limbic
hijacks and all those things well it's
important to acknowledge that's already
an AI right it's already a type of
artificial intelligence that is taking
personal collecting personal data about
me and then looking at the totality of
content that it can draw from
and being able to create a news feed for
me that continues to learn based on
uh what is stickiest for me right what I
engage with the most
um now in this case the AI is creating
the content it's just choosing which
content gets put in front of people
in doing so it is now incentivizing all
content creators to create the content
that does best on those algorithms so
it's actually in a way farming all human
content creators
because it's incentivizing them to do
whatever it is that is within the
algorithms bidding now as soon as we
have
synthetic media which is rapidly
emerging where we can
uh not just have humans creating
whatever The Tick Tock video is but we
can have deep fake versions of them that
are being created very rapidly
and now you have a curation AI where the
that first ones AI was just to curate
the stickiest stuff personalized to
people and creation AIS that can be
creating multiple things to split tests
relative to each other in the feedback
loop between those you can just see that
the problem that has been there just
hypertrophies
um
let alone the breakdown of the epistemic
comment and the ability to tell what is
real and not real and all those types of
issues
[Music]
um
I want to come back to where we were
so
obviously the curation algorithm
is saying that it's aligned with human
intent but not really right it's aligned
with human intent because it's giving
stuff that they empirically like because
they're engaging with it
but most people then
actually end up having regret of how
much time they spend on those platforms
and wish that they did less of it and
they don't plan in the day I want to
spend this much time Doom scrolling
and so is it
is it really aligned with their intent
and in general is aligning with intent
that includes the lowest angels of
people's nature type intense is that a
good thing is that a good type of
alignment when you factor the totality
of effects it has
um
so
we could say that the solution to the
algorithm issue should be that
because the social media platform is
gathering personal data about me
and it's Gathering based on its ability
to model my psyche based on all of who
my friends are and what I like and what
I don't like and all those things and my
mouse hover patterns it has an amount of
data about me that can model my future
Behavior better than a lawyer or a
psychotherapist or anybody else could
so there are Provisions in law of
um privileged information right if you
have privileged information what are you
allowed to do with it
and there are Provisions in law about
undue influence
so we could argue that the platforms are
gathering privileged information that
they have undue influence as a result
there should be a fiduciary
responsibility this is one of the things
that we do when there's a radical
asymmetry of power because if there's a
symmetry of power we say caveat M2 or
buyer beware it's kind of on you to make
sure that you don't get sold a shitty
thing or engaged with but if there's a
radical asymmetry of power can you tell
the kid buyer beware about an adult that
is playing them no you can't right
um and so in that way can the person who
isn't a doctor know that they really
don't need a kidney transplant if the
doctor tells them that they do because
the doctor gets paid when they give
kidney transplants well that's so bad we
don't want that to happen we make law
saying doctors can't do that
there's a Hippocratic oath to act not
just in their own economic interests but
in they are a they are an agent on
behalf of the principal because the
principal cannot buy or beware right
and so then there is a board of other
doctors who are also at that upper
asymmetry who can verify did the person
do malpractice or not same with a lawyer
if the lawyer wanted to just bill by the
15-minute sections maximally to drain as
much money from me they could because
there's no way I can know that what
they're telling me about law is wrong
because they have so much asymmetric
knowledge relative to me that we have to
make that illegal we have to make sure
that the lawyer is a
uh agent on behalf of me is the
principal so with lawyers and doctors
and
um therapists and uh financial advisors
we have this fiduciary principle agent
binding thing right and it's because
there's such an asymmetry that there
cannot be self-protection right if I'm
engaging with them and giving them this
privileged information and they wanted
to me they could right
and so but for my own well-being I have
to engage with them and give them this
information so we have to have some
legal way of binding that but of course
in the case to bind it where the lawyers
all have some practice law that they can
be bound by they can be shown they did
malpractice and same with doctors that
requires a legal body of lawyers or a
body of doctors that can assess if what
that doctor or Laura did was wrong so
somebody else that has even higher
asymmetry right a group of the top
things this becomes very hard when it
comes to AI
so let's start by saying the rather than
the aib and a
rival risk relationship with me
when I'm on social media and it is
actually Gathering the information about
me not to optimize my well-being but to
optimize ad sales for other for the
corporation that is the platform and the
corporations that are its actual
customers
right in which case it has the incentive
to uh prey on the lowest angels of my
nature and then be able to say it was my
intent and I had free choice
so we could say that should be a
violation of the principal agent issue
and because there's undue influence we
can show there's undue influence
consellience project we wrote some
articles on this
um there's one on undue influence that
makes this argument more deeply
um and because you can show its
Gathering privileged information it
should be in fiduciary relationship
where it has to pay attention to my
goals and optimize aligned with my goals
rather than I'm the product and it's
optimizing the goals of the corporation
or its customers right in order to do
that that would change its business
model it couldn't have an ad model
anymore it would I would either have to
pay a monthly fee for it
or the state or some Commons would have
to pay for it and everybody had access
to it or some other thing
um
that seems like a very good step in the
right direction
and that is an alignment issue thing
right the principal agent issues a way
of trying to solve the alignment which
is to say that this more powerful AI
system here the curatorial AI no social
media would be aligned with my interest
in Bound in some way
and maybe that maybe we would extend
that to all types of AI well of course
in the AGI case where it becomes fully
autonomous
and becomes more powerful than any other
systems what other system can check it
to see if what it is doing is actually
aligned or not there isn't a group of
lawyers
they can check that lawyer right so that
becomes a big issue and if it really
becomes autonomous as opposed to
empowering a corporation which is run by
humans
it's different
um
and
uh so this is one part on the topic of
alignment and alignment with Our
intention or well-being you can do
superficial alignment with Our intention
which the social media thing already
does but it's not aligned with our
actual well-being because an asymmetric
agent is capable of exploiting your
sense of intentionality
um so
and similarly
when you say there's a common sense that
says don't break the door down when
you're bringing me coffee there should
be a common sense that says
don't overfish the entire ocean and cut
all the damn trees down and turn them
into forests in the process of growing
GDP and there is clearly not
right
um and so we can see that the current
without AI human world system already
actually doesn't have that kind of check
and balance in it in all the areas that
it should just so long as the harms are
externalized somewhere far enough that
we don't instantly notice them and
change them
so the question of what do we if we have
radically more powerful Optimizer than
we already have
what do we align its goal with if we
just say align it with our intention but
it can change our intentions it can
Behavior mod me and we can't possibly
deal with that because of the asymmetry
that's no good as in the Facebook case
if we
try to align it with the interest of a
nation-state that can drive arms races
with other ones in other Nation States
in war or drive it align it with the
current economy that's misaligned with
the biosphere that's not good
um so the topic of alignment is actually
an incredibly deep topic
and this now gets to what you've
probably addressed on your show in other
places it gets to a very philosophic
issue which is the kind of is awe issue
which is science can say what is it
can't say what ought right and that kind
of Distinction by mail and others
historically and that the applied side
of science as Technology and Engineering
can change what is
but what ought to be what is the ethics
that is somehow compatible with science
is a challenge a
the best answer we have had arguably
that came from the mind that created
both a lot of our nuclear technology
and
uh our foundations of AI Von Neumann was
Game Theory right that the idea that is
good is the idea that doesn't lose
hmm and we can arguably say that that
thing instantiated by markets
and National Security protocols has
actually been
the dominant definition of ought
that go that ends up driving the power
of Technology because if science says we
can't say what ought we can't we can
only say what is but we're really
powerful at saying what is in a
way that reduces to technology that
changes what is where we can optimize
some metrics and say it's good even if
we externalize a lot of harm to other
metrics or optimizing groups with
expensive outgroups or whatever it is
right
and but we say that not only do we not
have an ought but that any system of is
not the philosophy of science
so is
insofar as that's concerned
out of scope or gibberish
well then what ends up to what ends up
guiding the power of Technology markets
do and to some extent National Security
does in other words rival risk and
theoretic kind of interests
and so what gets researched the thing
that has the most Market potential
and
um
so then again it is what is actually
developing the technology because as
Einstein said like
I was developing science not knowing it
was going to do that application didn't
want that application wanted Sciences
for social responsibility but what ends
up for the most part the research that
gets funded is r d towards something
that ends up either advancing the
interest of an Asian State or the
interest of a corporation or whatever or
whatever the metric set the game
theoretic metric set
of the group of people that is doing the
thing right
um
and so what I would say is that as we
get to more and more powerful is more
and more powerful science it creates
more and more powerful Tech and
exponentially powerful Tech especially
as we're already hitting fragility of
the planetary systems and when we say
more powerful we mean like exponentially
more powerful not iteratively more
powerful
the ha you have to have a system of auth
powerful enough to guide bind and direct
it
because if you don't it is powerful
enough to in whatever it is optimizing
for
destroy enough that what it optimizes
for doesn't matter anymore
now this is a fundamentally deep
metaphysical philosophical issue
and of course when we talk about
regulation law
basis of laws jurisprudence right and is
odd questions right applied ethics that
get institutionalized
um for exactly this reason and so when
we say if we have Tech that is powerful
enough to do pretty much
anything
what should be guiding that and what
should be binding it
and if we don't answer those well what
is the default of what will be guiding
guiding as and binding it currently and
what does that world look like
so this is super cheerful conversation
what is the call to action
like
okay we're quite a far ways away from
that
um let me try to expedite a couple other
parts when we were mentioning the AI
risk we said
um AI empowering Bad actors so you can
think about
whether a bad actor is a domestic
terrorist who the left who the best
thing they can do right now is get an
AR-15 and shoot up a Transformer station
to take down the power lines
um AR-15 is a kind of tech that has some
capability as you have more people
getting a sense of
uh
uh being disenfranchised by the current
system and being motivated to utilize
what is at their resources to do
something about it and the barrier of
Entry of the more powerful Tech is
getting lowered
um you can put those things together
right and
but whether you're talking about
domestic terrorism like that or you're
talking about International terrorism
from larger groups or you're talking
about full military applications
um but let's just go ahead and say and
like
can we make
deep fakes
um
that make the worst kinds of
uh confusion conspiracy theory in group
out group thinking propaganda of course
right like that is an emerging
technology that's eminent can we
um can we use people's voices and what
looks like their video and text for
um Ransom and up stuff
um can we like so you can think of all
the bad actor applications and then you
can pretty much apply it to
this is a piece of theory I wanted to
say every technology has certain
affordances when you build it it can do
things where without that technology you
couldn't do those things right attractor
allows me to do things that I couldn't
do without a tractors of the show in
terms of volume and types of work and
various things
um
every technology is also combinatorial
with other Tech because what a hammer
can do if I don't have a saw to cut the
timber first is very different than what
it can do if you have that and obviously
it requires the blacksmithing to make
the hammer right so you have you don't
just have individual Tech you have Tech
ecosystems and the combinatorial
potential of these pieces of tech
together have different performances
right so
but then what do we use it for is based
on the motivational landscape I can use
something like a hammer to be Jimmy
Carter and build houses for the homeless
of Habitat for Humanity or I can use it
as a weapon and kill people with it
um and so the tech has the affordances
to do both of those so the tech will be
developed and utilized based on
motivational Landscapes sure and just
briefly and going back to earlier it's
not just dual because that would be
double edges multi-polar Omni yes okay
so what we can say is the tech will end
up getting utilized by all
all
potentially getting utilized by all
agents for all motives that that tack
offers affordances relevant to their
motives
right and so when we're building a piece
of tech we don't want to think about
what is our motive to use it we want to
think about are we making a new capacity
that didn't exist before lowering the
barrier of Entry to a particular kind of
capacity where now what are all the
motives that all agents have who have
access to that technology and what is
the world that results from everybody
utilizing it that way
that's factoring second third fourth
order thinking into the development of
something a new capacity that changes
the landscape of the world
I would say that every scientist who is
working on synthetic bio for curing
cancer or AI for solving some awesome
problem
every scientist and engineer and Etc has
a an entrepreneur and ethical
responsibility to think about
the new capability they're bringing into
the world that didn't exist not just how
they want to use it
but the totality of use that will happen
by them having brought it into the world
it wouldn't had they not
right
there is no current when I say there's
ethical responsibility there is no legal
responsibility there is no fiduciary
responsibility where you are liable for
the harms that get produced by a thing
that you bring about that someone else
reverse engineers and uses a different
way
but there is financial incentive and
Nobel prizes for developing the thing
for your purpose
and then again socializing the losses or
whatever anybody else does with it
so this is one of those cases where the
personal near-term narrow motive this is
us being narrow AIS in an
ethical sense
um is to do the thing even if the net
result of the thing ends up being
catastrophically harmful
right so they're the incentive deterrent
the motivational landscape is messed up
so every Tech
now I want to make a couple more
philosophy of tech arguments Tech is not
values neutral
meaning that the hammer is not good or
bad it's just a hammer whether you use
it to build a house with a homeless or
meet someone's head is up to you that
the motivational landscape and the tech
have nothing to do with each other this
is not true
if a technology
gives the capacity to do something that
provides Advantage relative advantage in
a competitive environment
whether it's one nation state competing
with another nation state or one
Corporation or One Tribe with another
one
if it provides significant competitive
Advantage if you use it a particular way
than anyone using it that way creates a
multi-polar trap that obligates the
others to use it that way
or a related way
and
so we end up getting a couple things
right this is the classic example of
used lattice if we think about and it's
because there's been so much analysis on
this example
if you think about the plow as a
technology that was one of the key
technologies that moved us from sub
Dunbar number hunter gatherer maybe
Horticultural subsistence cultures to
large agricultural
civilizations
the plow is not a neutral technology
where you can choose to use it or not
choose to use it the populations that
used it made it through famines and grew
their populations way faster than the
ones who didn't and they used their much
much larger populations to win at Wars
right so the mean set that goes along
with using it ends up making it through
Evolution the means that the doesn't
doesn't make its revolution
and correspondingly
there are in order to implement the tech
it has ethical consequences I had the
clear-cut in order to do the kind of row
cropping
um that the plow really makes possible
I have to
get a open piece of land that is now
being used for just human food
production and not any other purpose so
I'm gonna clear cut the forest or a
meadow or something to be able to do
that
I'm going to
um so I'm already starting the
anthropocene with that right changing
natural environments from whatever
value they whatever habitat in the home
they were for all the life that was
there to now serving the purpose of
optimizing human productivity
and I have to yoke an ox and I probably
have to castrate it and do a bunch of
other things to be able to make that
work and probably beat dogs all day to
keep pulling the plow in order to do
that I have to move from the animism of
um I respect the great spirit of the
Buffalo and we kill this one with
reverence knowing that as it nourishes
our bodies our bodies will be put in the
dirt and make grass that its ancestors
will eat in part of the great circle of
life and whatever kind of idea like that
to it's just a dumb animal it's put here
for human purposes man's dominion over
it doesn't have feelings like us that
kind of thing which then spills over to
it's just it's not like us so we remove
our empathy from it and we apply that to
other races other classes other species
other whatever right
um
so
something like the plow is not values
neutral to be able to utilize it I have
to rationalize its use realizing it
creates certain externalities and if I
see those externalities I have to be I
have to have a value system that goes
along with that
wait sorry to be particular with the
word choice it's not that the plow is
not value neutral it's the use of the
plow exactly exactly
and that the plow doesn't use itself
right and so the use of the plow not
values neutral now a life where I am
hunting and Gathering versus a life
where I'm plowing are also totally
different lives
so it codes a completely different
Behavior set
in doing that it makes completely new
Mythos which is why the hunter gather
Mythos and The Agrarian Mythos are
completely different right and they have
different views towards men and women
and towards Sky Gods versus animism and
towards all kinds of things
and so but the other thing is that it
provides so much game theoretic
advantage of those who use it relative
to those who don't when they hit
competitive situations that's why there
are not many hunter-gatherers left and
why the whole society went agricultural
so it's not just that the tech so the
tech could the tech requires people
using it which changes the patterns of
human behavior changing the patterns of
human behavior automatically changes the
patterns of perception in human psyche
metaphors cultures Etc and the
externalities that it creates and the
benefits that it causes become implicit
to the value system because the value
system can't be totally in commensurate
with the power system
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy